ええワンビーシュタんえかんさまやん
婆伽婆さわってやん ヴィーラティジェータワニーアナータピンディカッサーラーミーってある時
モサカサマーガギオンショージャネストンベーラ時の話です
テーナコーパナサマエーナアーヤスマクマーラカッサポーアンダワニヴィーラティ
テーナコーパナサメーナ
その時 あのアーヤスマクマーラカッサポークマーラカッサパという名前のこの大長老ですね
アンデワニヴィーラティマル森なんですけど
名前はアンデワナという
時の話なんです
アタコーアンニャタラーデーヴァタービッカンターエラッティアービッカンタワンナーケーワラカッパンジェアンダワナンオーバーセッツーアーエーナアヤスマクマーラカッサポーテーヌパサンカミー
ウパサンカミットワーエーカマンタンアッターシー
アタコーアンニャタラーデーヴァター
その時 ある神がアビッカンターエラッティアー
ラッティアーっていうのは夜なんですけど
アビッカンターっていうのは夜かなり過ぎてからなんですね
まあ大体真夜中というふうな意味だと思いますけどね
アビッカンタっていうのはできましたということで
まあいわゆる まあ何て言いますか
過ぎてからっていうことなんですね
次にアビッカンタワンナー
その場合はアビッカンタっていうのは違う意味なんですね
ものすごい美しいっていうことで
あのワンナーっていうのは体のことなんですね
アビッカンタっていうのは乗り越えたという意味で取ってます
どちらにしたって追い起こしたっていうことで
だからラッティアービッカンタといえば
夜をもう追い越してるんですね
ですから 真夜中の意味で取ってます
アビッカンタワンナー
ワンナーっていうのは体の美しいことで
それもまあ追い越してるんですね
ケーワラカッパンアンダワナンオーバーセッツーア
ケーワラカッパンっていうのはもう完全にまとめて
アンダワナンアンダワナというところをオーバーセッツーア輝かして
で この神の美しさでもうアンデワナというところがもう完全にもう輝いてしまったという
まあ大体デーヴァターっていうのは女性か男性かということはあまりわからないことなんですけど
デーヴァターっていうのは女性名詞なんですね
とにかく ですから 男性の場合はデーヴァプットーという言葉使っているんです
デーヴァターという言葉自体がもともと女性名詞なんですね
ですから おそらくある女神が来た可能性もあります
エーナアヤスマクマーラカッサポーテーヌパサンカミー
クマーラカッサパ長老がいるところに行って
そこに行った 行ったんです
ウパサンカミットワーエーカマンタンアッターシー
まあ近寄って側に立ちました
エーカマンタンティタークーサーデーヴァターアヤスマンタンクマーラカッサパンエータドゥーチョー
その神が あの まあ近く立ってクマーラカッサパ尊者にこういう風なことを言うんですね
ビックービックーアヤンワンニコーラッティカンドゥーマヤティーディヴァパッジャラティー
ブラームノデーヴァマーハアビッカナスメーダサッタンアーダーヤーティ
アビッカナントスメードーサッタンアーダーヤアッドアサランガンランギバンバダンテーティ
ブラームノデーヴァマーハウッキペランギンアビッカナスメーダサッタンアーダーヤーティ
アビッカナントスメードーサッタンアーダーヤアッドアサウッドゥマーイカンウッドゥマーイカーバダンテーティ
ブラームノデーヴァマーハウッキペウッドゥマーイカンアビッカナスメーダサッタンアーダーヤーティ
アビッカナントスメードーサッタンアーダーヤアッドアサディヴァーパタンディヴァーパトーバダンテーティ
ブラームノデーヴァマーハウッキペディヴァーパタンアビッカナスメーダサッタンアーダーヤーティ
その神がこのクマーラカッサパ長老に何か質問を出すんですね
そのクマーラカッサパという尊者にはクマーラっていうのは一応プリンスという意味でも使いますけど
王子という意味です で
一般的に王家の男の男たちに使う言葉でもありますが
パーリ語では普通子供という意味で使ってるんですね
クマーラといえば男の子
クマリーといえば女の子ですね
子供だからちょっと褒め称えて王子様と王女様という風に言っていることなんです
そこでこのクマーラカッサパといえば
このカッサパという子供という意味になっちゃうんですね
だから名前はカッサパで
なんでクマーラカッサパになったでしょうかって
別に王子様というわけではないんですけどね
随分子供の時 ものすごい小さい時出家したんですね
出家できる一番小さい時出家してしまったんですね
この尊者が本当はこのあるシャミ
シャミじゃなくて何でしたっけ
こちらは書いてないんですけど
このある女の人が妊娠したままで出家した
ね それで妊娠したことは知らなかったんです
それでどんどんお腹が大きくなってくると
もう大変なもの問題になりまして
あの なんでね 出家した人が妊娠したんでしょうかと
で まあそれはお釈迦様に対しても
他の比丘たちに対しても
もう大変な問題になってきたんですね
でものすごく批判されたし
されたし それでお釈迦様はもう何のことなく彼女まあ大富豪のところで出家していたんだというふうに言ってますけどね
結構女の人々がもう大富豪のところに出家していたんですね
贅沢したかったでしょう
おそらく出家しても 大富豪は追い出しちゃったんです
彼女は還俗したくないし
自分が戒律を破ってないんだよというふうにものすごく言ってるんですね
戒律のことにいたっては
あんたお腹が大きいでしょうということで
まあそれでお釈迦様がこの妻家の審査会を設定してね
アナードプリンギル尊者とビサーカー夫人と王様とかね
まあ何人かこの審査会を設定して
まあ特にビサーカー夫人にこれちゃんと調べて報告しなさいと言った
言伝ついたところで ビサーカー夫人が彼女を調べて
まあまあ全部日にちやら全部計算して
まあ王様とアナードプリンギル尊者は信者さんの代表
王様は政府の代表で まあ彼女は女性の問題だから
この女性がその問題に当たったんですけども
まあ彼女は出家する前にまあ妊娠していたんだと
それ知らないで出家したんだと
ということがまあ人のコミティで決めて
結論をお釈迦様に出すんですね
まあ出されたところでお釈迦様が
じゃあ彼女は戒律破ってないんだから
まあ還俗する必要はないと
まあお釈迦様決めるんです
それでお釈迦様は還俗する必要ないと言ったら
もう他の誰にもそれに逆らうことはできませんし
王様も代表で参加したんだからね
彼女に対していろいろ批判やらね
何も言うこともそれっきりでできなくなったんですね
でもまあ一応お寺でまあ子供は産んでしまいましたけど
まあ王様がやっぱりあなた方はね
まあ修行するために出家したんだからね
子育てに手をかけちゃうとね
これ冗談ではないと ですからもう子供を返せと
返せと言えないね 子供まあ取るんですね
王様が 王様は自分で子供をもらって
宮殿で育てるんですね
で でも自分でなんとか歩き回れるぐらいになってくると
彼がやっぱり自分には母親がいないっていうことをなんか気になって
それからまあ宮殿で育てられたんだけど
まあもう格がないんですね
で みんなこのかなりいじめがあったと思いますね
やっぱり王様はそんなこと知るわけじゃないし
まあそういう社会っていうのはかなり激しい社会でしょうしね
まあだからまあお前誰の男かわからないやとかね
一般人の男ではないかと
なんでこちらのね 王家の人々の間でもえらそうに王子様扱いとか何とかとか
まあ他の女たちの子供たちもいたんだからね
かなりもう喧嘩になったり
いろいろ事になっていて
その子はやっぱりそれも気に入らないんですね
それでまあだったら私はもう出ていくんだと
出家するんだと まあ言ったところで
まあ王様がそれを許可するんです
まあそれだったらいいでしょうと
それで随分小さい時出家してしまったんですね
で まあ結構小さい時から真面目に修行して
まあかなりお釈迦様に可愛がってもらったみたいなような感じもあるしね
であの悟ったんですね
で かなり大らかになりましてね
ものすごい説法上手ですよ
もう言葉を巧みに使える人でね
ですからクマーラカッサパというふうに名前を付けたのは
一応名前はカッサパで
お釈迦様がいろいろ美味しいものとか何とかとか頂いたら
比丘たちにこれはカッサパにあげなさいとかね
お菓子やら何かが入ったらもうもうカッサパにあげなさいと言っちゃうんですね
だからカッサパの名前でたくさんいるんだから
どちらのカッサパだったらクマーラカッサパにあげなさいと
だからまあ王様の宮殿のところから来て出家した人だからね
まあそれでまあお釈迦様はいつでもクマーラカッサパ
クマーラカッサパと言うんだから
一応この名前になってしまったんですね
ですから子供という意味でもなくて
坊主という意味でもなくないんですね
まあ子供といっても毎日成長して大人になってしまっちゃうし
もう大人なんですけども
この時になってくると
で 王家の人っていうわけでもないんです
王家の人でもクマーラという名前を出家したら使わない
誰にも 捨てますしね だからこのお坊さんに
お釈迦様がこうやって言っていたんだから
そのあだ名がついてしまったんです
で これで昔話の注釈書にありまして
このパドマッタラというブッダの時代で
この人は裕福な家庭で生まれていたんです
それでそのパドマッタラというブッダがあるお坊さんに
ものすごく美しく綺麗に説法できるという
説法できるお坊さんとして
ある一人のお坊さんにこの名誉というかね
一応何て言いますか 名前
位を与えたんですね この弟子たちの中で
この第一人者ですよと
この説法上手な人の中でとか
そこを見ていたんですね
だから あまりにもすごい尊い名誉号っていうのはね
お釈迦様 お釈迦様ではなくて
パドマッタラブッダからね
与えてくれるのは 見ていて
その豊かなこの人が感動して
私もそういうふうな位をいただきたいなとかね
今世は無理ですから そこでその日から祈願して
そのブッダに一生懸命お布施をして
自分が徳で祈願するんですね
それからもうたくさん徳を積んで
お釈迦様のブッダのお話なんか聞いても
心の中にあるのはすぐ悟ることじゃなくて
今のブッダのところではできないんだけど
将来でもどこかのブッダのところで
私もそれぐらいの格をいただいて悟りますよということになって祈願していたんだから
それでお釈迦様の前に現れたブッダはカッサパブッダと言うんですけど
このカッサパブッダの時は出家していたんです
出家していて すごい真剣に修行するんですね
修行するんだけど 過去から考え方が違うんだからね
で まだまだ徳を完成してないんです
このお釈迦様から ブッダから位を得るためには
それなりの人格を完成しなくちゃいけないんですね
そこら辺 誰にもあげるわけじゃないし
まあ人しかね お釈迦様から名誉をもらってないしね
ですから それはそれなりの偉大なる人物でないとできないことだから
まだまだ徳を積まなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから カッサパブッダの時でも一生懸命修行していますけど
悟らないんですね 悟らないんだけど
瞑想はうまくいっているんですね
進んでいくんですね ですから
いろいろ禅定なんかは出来上がりますけど
悟りの方向へは行かないんです
[背景音楽]そこでカッサパお釈迦様が涅槃に入って亡くなっちゃうんですね
亡くなったら ある五人の比丘たちが我々はまだ悟ってないんだと
もう自分たちがちょっと気が緩んでいるんだと
思って ある山に登るんです
山というか崖なんですね
崖に登って はしごを作って
崖に登って 崖の上になって
はしごを捨てて はしごを捨てたらもう降りられません
はしごでなきゃ登れないんです
で ここでじゃあやりましょうと
それぐらいもう覚悟して
もう悟るか死ぬかどちらかなんですね
修行を始めたんです その中の一番年上の長老が三日目で悟り開くんですね
二番目の長老は四日目になるともう悟り開くんです
もう行くところもないし
降りられませんし だから二十四時間を一生懸命瞑想だけしているんですね
それで四日目で悟るといっても不還果に悟るんですね
他の三人がなかなか悟らないんです
で そのまま亡くなっちゃうんです
あの二人は降りて帰っちゃったんですけどね
で 降りて帰って食事やら自分の能力で
超能力で持ってきたんだけどね
そういう約束はなかったと
ですからもう断りますと言って
食事は全部断ったんですね
そうやって修行して やっぱりもうご飯も何も食べないとね
そんなに体持つわけじゃないし
亡くなっても天界に生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
その三人がこのカッサパブッダから釈尊までというのはものすごい長い
何光年もかかります で
すぐブッダが現れるということはないんです
人類に一人しか現れないんです
ですから 次のブッダが現れるということは
これは全部宇宙も破壊にならない限りはね
また出てこないんです
で いろいろこのまあものすごい徳を積んだ方々だからね
いろんな天界に生まれ変わったり
人間にまた生まれ変わったり
もう大変な幸福で ずっと地獄に落ちることはないし
ずっと生まれ変わってきて
一応お釈迦様が現れた時代でも
ちょうど合わせてね それで生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
人間の世界で 一人がこのタクシラという
今あの恐らくこのカシミールの地方に入っている場所やと思いますけどね
そちらの王様として そちらで生まれて
プッカサという名前の王様で生まれるんです
これは一応学者もね ちゃんとした話として認めるところなんですね
このプッカサという名前の王様が実際にいたみたいですね
だからその王様がブッダの話を聞いて
ブッダがいるんだと すぐもう王をやめて
全部捨てて出てきて 出家するんです
だからそれは大変な出来事で
お釈迦様でも王様ではなかったんですね
出家した時は だからそんなに国を自分に任されたという責任はなかったんです
まだ父親がいましたからね
で 一応 一応皇太子というか
王のような感じにしておいたんだけど
そんな責任があったわけじゃないし
ものすごく若かったし
ですから お釈迦様が出家するということよりは
このプッカサ王様が家出したということは大変な出来事なんです
国の権力取っていた 国を治めていた王がある日突然いないということだから
どこに行ったかも何も誰もわからない
何のことも言わずに ずっともう何も持たずに出て行っちゃったんです
出て行って お釈迦様に会って出家するんです
[背景音楽]そこで彼が遠くから歩いて来るんだっていう話を知ってお釈迦様も
これは大騒ぎになるお話だからね
やっぱりそんなにね 一人で歩けるわけじゃないしね
やっぱりお釈迦様迎えに行くんです
で 行く道で迎えに行って
もう王ではないしね やっぱり王様っていうのはかなり格が一番高いでしょうし
で これでカースト制度から格の家の制度から見ると
この格の低いんですよ
このいろいろこういう例えばこの宝石作る
装飾品作る人やらね 服を洗うカーストとかね
全部カースト制度と決めてるんです
カーストって言っても職業制度なんですね
だから で その中でこの食器作る
食器っていうのは土で作るんですから
今のものみたいにすごい美しく焼くということでもないんですけどね
その食器作る職人がいて
その人は結構 カーストはカーストなんですけど
かなり金持ちなんです
で 彼がこの大きなこのこの焼けない焼き物を焼かなくちゃいけないし
ですからかなり大きな建物を持ってるんです
それでプクソウ様がもう出家してね
出家の形で来て 今日夜ちょっと泊まらせていただけませんか？と言ったら
彼がもうこんなバカでかいホールがありますから
どうぞ座ってくださいと
と許可出すんですね でお釈迦様もまた違う地方からね
歩いてきて 夜になったんだから
どこかに泊まらなくちゃいけない
それでまたこの食器作る職人のところに行って
今日は泊まるとこはないんですけど
あなたの建物いかがでしょうかと
貸してくれますか？と言ったら
この人がもうもうちょっと先にね
他の行者が来て その人にあげましたよと
だから彼が嫌と言ったらもうどうしようもないんだと
ですから彼に聞いてみてくださいと
彼 OK というならば 別に私には関係ないんだということで
お釈迦様は何のことなく
その出家のプクソウ様のところに行って
私も遠くから歩いてくるんですけど
今日夜ここで泊まってもよろしいですか？と聞いたら
まあいいでしょうと それで泊まるんですね
だからお互いに知らない
お釈迦様は知ってるんだけど
この人は知らない それでお釈迦様はだいたい夜寝ないしね
お釈迦様はちゃんと禅定に入って
もう何のことなくいるんですね
そこでこの人もまあただ出家したのはしたんだけど
お釈迦様のために出家したんですから
まだわからないし 何一つ
で まあいろいろ真似しながらいるんですね
とにかく自分としても恥ずかしいし
自分がいびきかけながら寝ちゃうとね
それもお釈迦様はちょっと狙ってやってることなんですね
まあ寝かせないということはね
で そうやってこのその人も頑張ってる
お釈迦様も頑張っているということで
なんとなくお互いに会話するような雰囲気を
お釈迦様は作って あの
いろいろ話をするんですね
言ったら あなたは名前なんでしょうか？と言って
こういう名前で あなたの先生は誰ですか？と聞いたら
それも釈迦牟尼仏ですよと
そう 会ったことはありますか？と
会ったことないと言って
それでただ普通に会話するんです
で 会話していろいろ宗教のことやら心のことやらいろいろ話をする
会話の途中でどんどんどんどんこの人は悟っていくんです
で 自分が悟り開いたら
なんかこれちょっと違うと分かって
それで聞くんですね 実際は逆さまではないかと
言ったら そうでしょう
そうですよと そこで彼に出家認めてあげて
そこで不還果に悟るんです
で だからお釈迦様を大変大事に考えた一人なんですね
フックスという王様がね
後で阿羅漢になりますけど
簡単に悟ります なぜならば
過去でもう命かけて修行した経験があったんだからね
それは無駄にならないんです
だから ちょっとお釈迦様とちょっと会話
日常的な会話をしただけでも悟ってしまいますからね
もう一人が かなり遠いなんですけど
もう海のところで ちょっとしたところで生まれて生まれたんですね
これはお釈迦様いるインドとはもう随分違う
もう南の方ですからね
そこで生まれて 海ですからね
やっぱり船に乗って あちこちまあ漁師か商売かわかりませんですけどね
出て行ったところで船が壊れちゃって
そこでも何とか知らないところにこのもう流されちゃうんですね
そこで服は着る服も何もなくて裸でしたから
この木の枝を取って 枝じゃなくてこの木の皮を取って
腰に巻いて浮いちゃったんですね
それを見たその島の人々は
おそらくこの人は普通じゃないと
これは仙人だよと思って
彼の面倒を見てあげたんですね
彼も何もわからないし
もしかすると言葉さえもわからなかった可能性もあるし
随分親切に丁寧にいろんなことを教えてくれるわ
尊敬もしてくる 彼もそれなりにもう生活しているんです
だから過去からの癖があるんだから
心は汚れません インチキはやりません
みんな行者として尊敬するんだから
自分も全部なくなったし
それから出家として生活したっても悪いわけじゃないし
だったらまあそうやって行者の出家沙門するんだよと
ということで そうすると長い間いるんですね
だから長い間心は汚れたことはないし
疑いが生まれたこともないし
落ち着いているんですね
それでこの仙人やとかね
阿羅漢やというふうなことで
みんなその人は阿羅漢やと言ってしまったんですね
言われてしまっちゃったんですね
彼ももしかするとそうかもしれませんと
もしかすると だって全然心は汚れませんしね
という気持ちになっちゃったんで
その気持ちになることは大変危険なんです
それであの一番前でパドマッタラでカッサパ釈迦ブッダのところで
この 5人の中でこの 2番目の長老が不還果になりましたからね
それで不還果になった人々は梵天に生まれ変わっちゃうんです
そこでもう寿命は長いんだから
もう長い もう何劫年かわからないほどいるんですからね
で やがてそこで悟るんです
また人間に戻るとは全くないんです
必ずも悟りますね その梵天の人が
そう これ気になっちゃったんです
自分の友達がね もう勘違いしてたんだと
それだけすごく気になっちゃって
これ勘違いでこれで困りますよと心配してるんです
それでその梵天の神がやっぱり彼のところに現れてきてね
叱るんですね いきなり
阿羅漢取るんじゃないんだよ
もう誰もそんなこと言わないんだからね
この勘違いするんじゃないんだよと
阿羅漢のどころか阿羅漢になる方法さえわからないんだと
ですから このそんなにも煩悩なく悟りたければ
もうブッダが現れてるんだから
ブッダに話を聞きなさいよ
と言ったら すぐその話を聞いた途端
彼ももうそこで全部畳んで
お釈迦様のところに歩いていくんですね
年月をかけて歩いていて
お釈迦様に会ってすぐ悟るんです
悟ってその日で亡くなります
阿羅漢の涅槃に入って亡くなりましたけどね
出家することはできなかったんです
で 一番一番短い時間で悟った人はその人なんですね
お釈迦様は托鉢途中で一言葉言ったの一言葉聞いただけで完全に悟ってしまうんですね
それで悟ったんだから
ではお釈迦様 私は出家お願いしますと
では衣を探してこいと
でお釈迦様はあまりいいですよと一言言わなかったんです
お釈迦様がいいですよと言うだけのことなんです
それで比丘なんですけど
じゃあ衣を探してくださいと
言ったら はい わかりましたと言って
あっちこっちで捨てた何か布切れとかあるんでしょうかとか
探してる途中で ある牛にやられちゃって死んじゃうんですね
亡くなっちゃう 阿羅漢ですからね
涅槃に入ってしまっちゃうんです
そこで牛に攻撃されちゃって
そこら辺のゴミ だいたいゴミのところを調べるんだからね
捨てた布切れ調べる だからいろいろゴミのところで歩く
歩いてるんです ゴミ ゴミの山とかね
それでゴミと一緒に もう遺体がそのまま
誰も知らないし 誰の誰かも知らないし
亡くなっちゃって でお釈迦様が比丘たちと一緒にそちらに行って
比丘たちにこの遺体をちゃんと運びなさいと寺まで運んでもらって
ものすごく丁寧にもう式というか火葬してあげちゃうんですね
してあげて この人はもう比丘で阿羅漢ですよと
ですから 特別に正式的に比丘になるともならなくたって
もう完全に悟ったんだから
それでもう比丘ですよと
阿羅漢ですよと だからみんな何か知らない
もうなんでもう顔も知らない人に
こんなにお釈迦様がね
真剣かっていうことがね
問題になるんだから みんなに発表してあげた
だから自分この人の位あげる場合は
そのダールチーリヤというバーヒ
名前バーヒなんですけど
このバーヒ尊者にも一つ位をあげたんです
その時はそのバーヒ尊者がいない
もう涅槃に入ってるんですね
一番短い時間で悟った人と
そういう記録は破ることはできません
そこで残りの方なんですね
3人目  3人目はもうなんかそこら辺でお釈迦様も最上の方なんですけど
そこら辺の誰かの女の子
お腹の中に入ってしまっちゃったんです
でもストーリー ブッダゴーサ長老も書いているみたいですね
クマーラ・カッサパ ちょっと待って
ブッダゴーサ長老も何言ってるんでしょうかね
その女の子も 最初からも結婚したくなかったんです
結婚はしたくないと とにかく出家したいんだと
だからもうその女性も生まれつき
やっぱり過去の影響もあって
心は汚れてないんですね
だから生まれても結婚はしたくないということでも
ものすごく激しく攻撃する
両親に私は結婚したくないと
だから出家したいんだと
だからお寺に出してくださいと
女性の場合はもう決まり厳しいし
女性っていうのは誰かに必ず守ってあげなくちゃいけないという
あの決まりっていうのは昔からあります
昔ありましたし ですから
結婚するまでは独立はできません
親の管理 だから出家したければ親がOK出さなくちゃいけない
それで親っていうのはずっと女の子を守ってあげて
誰かに男にあげるんですね
結婚として そうするとその男の管理の中になっちゃうんですね
だから自由にはなりません
独立はなりません 独立には
それも時々経典に出てくるんですね
女性っていうのは不幸だと
死ぬまで独立できませんと
若い時は親に管理されちゃって
それから結婚したら旦那に管理されて
そこで子供が大きくなったら子供に管理されるんだと
死ぬまで独立にはなりませんと
だからそういうことで女っていうのは不幸だよという言葉あるんですね
そういう言葉取って お釈迦様は女性差別しているんだいという連中がいるんだから
今最近 最近ではなくて
昨日の夜からものすごく私はまたもう爆破寸前状態なんです
で 朝も一応いくらかの返事を書いて出しましたけどね
で 夜書こうかなと思ったら
やっぱりもういきなり頭に浮かんだばっかし書いちゃうと
これあまりにもキツすぎだからね
もうちょっと あのもう何て冷える冷えるまで待とうと一晩待っても
やっぱり夜も気になるんで
とにかく書いてやらなくちゃと
朝 それを一部だけやって
まあそれやってもほんの早い返事で
これからもう徹底的にまとめてまた書かなくちゃって
また余計なことで先にそれ質問に答えを出していたんだからね
またもう だから人がね
人々がアホだから アホだからといってこちらまで困る必要ないと思いますけどね
まあ確かにもういろんな経典でそうやってお釈迦様は女性のことはね
言ってるところがあるんです
欲ばっかしだよと  1 日中
それは差別することじゃないんです
当時の女のことを見て言ってることなんですね
欲ばっかしだよと言ったところはもう
その通りです 家のことばっかしか考えない
それで子供のこと 旦那のこと
それしかそれ以外全然頭が動かないんですね
だからもう昔の女性っていうのは厳しく守られていたんだから
自分にとっては今日本の女みたいにね
もう結婚して遊びたい放題あっちこっち遊ぶっていう
そんな汚らわしい性格はなかったし
ですから この自分にとっては
相手としては自分の旦那しかないでしょうし
ですからもう旦那のことで頭いっぱいですね
子供が生まれたから子供のことでまた頭いっぱい
だからそれしか考えてないんだと
それはちょっとしたことでものすごく怒るんだよと
そんなものは当たり前のことで
決して差別じゃないんです
当時の女性の状況はもう言っただけで
それでもう出家して悟りたければ
その欠点を直さなくちゃいけないんです
煩悩っていうのはいろんな形をとって現れるでしょうに
だから当時の女性たちには
そういうところで煩悩が機能しているんです
だからもうものすごくお釈迦様がものすごい厳しく言うんです
それを見て女性差別しているんだそうとか
だから私の今日これから書くポイントは
仏典の中で女性の方よりは男性の方が当たり前
ものすごい数が多かったでしょ？お釈迦様の周りにいるのはみんな男たちだけでしょ？で
どんな経典でも比丘たちに喋ってるでしょうに
だからお釈迦様にずっと経典の中で九十五パーセント以上男を馬鹿にされてるんです
男を非難されてるんで
どんな経典でも貶されてるんです
でも一人の男もお釈迦様が男性差別してるんだよと言ってないんです
どんな男でもお釈迦様に対して向かって
なんだあなたはね 我々男たちをバカにしてとかね
貶してとかね 読んでみても
経典で全部男に向かって言ってることでしょうに
ゴミ扱いされてるでしょうに
悟った人だけお釈迦様が随分親切に優しく
だからこれすごい もう見ても
お釈迦様っていうのはみんなもう全く相手にしない
それでクマーラカッサパとかね
過去生からもう頑張ってる人だったらお菓子ぐらいでもくれるとかね
こんな特別扱いしちゃうと
他の人々から見れば腹立つはずでしょうね
なんでそんなに特別扱いするんでしょうかとか
それでプッカサトー王様の場合
お釈迦様をもう一生懸命一人でも長い道のりを歩いていらっしゃるんだから
だからそういう特別な人
それがサーリプッタ目連尊者とか
それ何人かに対しては随分親切な顔を見せるんだけど
他の人々だったらかなりきついでしょうね
なのに一人も男が今までお釈迦様は男性差別しているんだよって言ってないんです
それでも二割ぐらい 二割もより少ないんですね
女性に向かって喋ったことは
それだけ あの大量の経典の中からそれだけ取って
なんだお釈迦様が女性差別しているんではないかと
いうことで 私がやっぱりお釈迦様の批判というのはぴったし合ってるんだと
だからお釈迦様は論理性はないんだと
判断は鈍いんだと ものすごい高慢だと
蛇のように怒るんだよと言ったことでしょうに
それ見ただけで それほどお釈迦様に悪口を言うんだったらね
冗談じゃないんだ お釈迦様が言うべきだから言ってるんであって
もしお釈迦様の弟子たちの場合は八十パーセント女性だったら
全部女性に対して語るんですよ
だって誰でも悟りの悟りへ導かなくちゃいけないでしょうし
なんで女性だけ生まれつき完璧で
何も間違いなくて というふうに喋らなくちゃいけないんですかね
だから俗世間で女性をいつでも褒め称えてくれる
おだててくれる 勘違いしているんです
仏教もおだててくれるんだぞとかね
褒め称え 女性っていうのは実に美しいものだよとかね
言ってないんです だからそれで女性差別やと言うとね
この勘違いもいいところなんですね
そこでそんな気持ちでいる女性っていうのは
一向に仏道にはもう縁がないしね
自分を褒めたて褒めてくれて
おだててくれて まだ仏道もできると
そんなありえないんです
私は前に書いたのは テーラワーダ仏教は初期仏教は女性差別しているんだったら
それはテーラワーダ社会で調べてみなさい
調べてみなさいと 社会学的にどれほど差別されているんでしょうかと
そう そうすると あの 何て言いますか
この被害者たちが文句言ってるでしょうに
文句言ってるのは日本の女性であって
ミャンマーの女性もタイの女性もスリランカ女性
全然一言も音を立てて文句を言ってないんです
差別されてるのそちらでしょ
初期仏教の教えで 日本で初期仏教のところ
お釈迦様の教え 一欠けらもないんだから
一欠けらもないところで何やと言うんだからね
だからもう で 厳しい言葉で言わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
まあお釈迦様が言うのは
やっぱりあのアホでもね
黙っているとわからないんだと
アホは黙っているとわからないでしょう
何者かと 喋るなよと 喋ったら全部バレますよと
同じことを言いたいんです
口を開けるなよと でも問題は
それに私が返事出しちゃうと
なんであなたはそんな態度でそんなに怒鳴りつけたり言葉書くんでしょうかと
別に怒ってないんですけど
向こうの間違いだから黙っていればよかったところで
まあ無駄話になりますから
一回言ったことはそれでもう完結して言ったつもりでしょうしね
また言いたくはないんです
だからこの  女性の話に出て申し訳ないんですけど
やっぱり確かに経典に女性をバカにしてねという言葉がいっぱいあるんで
いっぱいではないんだけど
もういくつかあるんです
それは女性のことをもう心配して言ってるんです
女性は悟れないと一言もおっしゃってないでしょうし
お釈迦様出家は嫌でした
それは発揮しているんです
出家はちょっと遠慮しなさいと
それは自分の母親のことだから
最初から出家したかったのはね
やっぱり出家しなくても修行して悟られるんだからね
余計な迷惑はかけたくないだけで
どう女性たちがね もう私たちはすごいよと威張ったっても
体がやっぱり弱いんですよ
そんな自然の中で 森の中で生活できるわけじゃないでしょうし
女性の体はそれなりにいろいろ違いますからね
男はどこでも山の上でも木の上でも生活できるんですけど
女性にはそれは無理でしょうし
ですから 守られた環境の中で
まあ旦那に食わせてもらって修行しなさいよと
そこら辺はお釈迦様の差別でも何でもないんです
今 現代になって独立をできたんだからといってね
威張るんじゃないんですよ
まあまあ たまたま社会環境変わってね
経済状況変わって 女性にも独立できるようになっただけのことです
で それでも独立できるかっていう問題があるでしょうに
自分でアパート借りたっても
それなりの安全対策していないと誰かに殺されるかわからないでしょうに
だから私はそんなもう頭が悪いんだからといってね
もう叫びない方がいいと思います
今も東京やらいろんなところ
大阪とかね まあ独立している女性たちがいっぱいいます
自分たちのアパートで一人暮らししているのは若い女性たちとかね
でも男たち一人暮らししているようなとこ
アパートなんかね 住めますかね
住めないでしょうに ものすごい特別女性専用のアパート
いろんなところであるでしょうし
だからまあ今も状況は変わってないんです
それなりのマンションでなければ
それなりのアパートじゃなくて
それなりの警備システムができてないと
管理システムができてないと
誰かに殺されちゃいますよ
それで女性も女性 自分の身を守る方法はわからない
誰か男がちょっとニコッと笑っちゃうと
そこずっと行っちゃうでしょうし
そこでお金は騙し取られるわ
携帯電話で何メール？出会い系
あれだけで出て行って殺されるでしょうに
だからお釈迦様がよくもよくも汚れてるんだいというのはどこが間違ってるんですかね
もうちょっと自分のこと気をつければいいでしょうに
なんで男は女は理解しない
男っていうのは女を騙すためにずっと
もうこれ人類初めから嘘をつくんですよ
男は自分のものにしたければ
もうものすごく褒め称える
すごい世界一やと あなたはとかね
言ったりする だからと
なんでそれに乗るんですかね
世界一わけじゃないでしょうに
そこで頭が悪いと言っているのは正しいんです
だから そのお釈迦様のことを真面目に聞けば
女性もしっかりします
男にはあんたすごく美人で
本当に可愛くていい加減にしなさいと
言えるぐらいは自信がつくでしょうに
そこで自分で調べて やっぱりこの人は真面目で真剣やと
ぞっこんと言うんですか
私に対してはもう一生懸命
もうもうまあなんて言いますか
あれは ぞっこん惚れてるんだと
他の女を見えないんだと
だったらこの人と一緒になっても
まあ一応守ってくれるでしょうというふうに正しく判断すればいいでしょうに
その判断ないでしょうに
全くもって 見た気に一回もう行ったと
だからそこは判断能力はないに越いということでしょうに
そんなことは私は差別とも何とも思わないのです
それが世界を 社会を改革する人が言うべきところなんです
怒鳴る場合は男にも怒鳴って女にも怒鳴るんです
欠点は堂々と言うので
ここら辺ダメですよと
お釈迦様は人間平等にしたかったんだから
もう言うことは言ってるだけであって
私はお釈迦様を女性差別して言ってる言葉っていうのは全部一つも否定しません
それは言って差別と言ったら
言われた側の理解の問題ですけどね
それは差別じゃない 女性の状況を何とかして改良したいんだから言ってるんであって
今も独立しているんだからといって
結局は状況は変わってないんです
今も誰かが守ってあげないと命が危ないんですね
昔はそこまではなくかったんだけど
携帯持っただけでも殺される状態になってるし
だからちょっとちょっと褒めただけで
男にちょっと嘘を言われただけで
もうそこにも引っかかっていくんですからね
そういう弱みをきちんと直さなくちゃいけない
覚る人が全ての煩悩をなくすんだから
そんなものは当たり前でしょうに
なくしてしまうということは
悟った世界で もう性別も何も関係ないんで
欲はないんだから とにかくその女性が小さい頃からやっぱり出家したかったんですね
でも親は認めない それで結婚させちゃったんですね
それで彼女が企んだのは
もう結婚したところで
お互いの気持ちの問題だからね
自分にそんな気持ちがないと
嫌々でいるんだということが分かったら
まあ男の人は解放してくれるんだぞと思っていたんですね
かなり考えていたんですね
それで結婚はした それで親はもう責任は放棄
放棄じゃなくて もう責任は終了
それでも旦那になっちゃうでしょうに
旦那と一緒にいたんだけど
彼女は全然もうもう家庭としては興味はない
男の人はこれからもうずっと 1人前でね
家族を築くために結婚するでしょうし
もう結婚した相手がなかなか向こうはほとんどお見合いだから
なかなかもうその気持ちではありませんだから
で 聞いたら何でしょうか言って
私は本当はもともともう結婚は嫌でしたと
性格は全くもう嫌ですよと
だからあなたの不幸になるんだよと私は言ったって
私はいい奥さんにはなりませんよと
出家したいんだと そしたらその男の人はそれだったらいいでしょうと言って許可出しちゃったんです
その人の他の女の人と結婚すればいいでしょうし
よくよく出されたところで出家するんですね
その時もう妊娠していたんですね
で それがこの5番目の人なんですね
だからその場合でも見えるのは
やっぱりこの生まれてくる子供っていうのは
やっぱりこの好き勝手にどんな女のおなかの中にも入るわけじゃなくて
何かの接点があるんですね
何か性格的に合うとかね
何か接点があって その人のおなかに入り込んじゃうんです
だからこの女性はやっぱりもう初めからもう出家主義で
もう欲を離れる主義でいましたし
だからこのクマーラカッサパ尊者も展開からね
生まれ変わる時はやっぱり欲に溺れてる女のおなかではなくて
やっぱり欲は嫌いということで
ものすごい精神的な清らかな心を持ってるところにすっともう引っかかってしまっちゃうんですね
だから後で大変な目に遭いましたけど
でもそれでもやっぱり性格はまあ合ってしまったんですね
そこで彼女がね まあそういうことになりまして
出家して妊娠してから出家しちゃって
まあコーサラ王様に子供が育てるようになりました
そこはクマーラカッサパ尊者の話
それで 5人のうち一人だけもう完全に悟りましてね
まあ一人が普賢果になって
あの３人がお釈迦様の時代でお釈迦様に出会って ３
人とも悟り開くんですね
だからこのクマーラカッサパ尊者も
もうバーヒヤ尊者が瞬時に悟ったでしょうに
だからこの方も出家し
ちっちゃい時出家したんだけど
もうすぐもう悟り開いてしまったんです
でも子供ですよ 子供ですけど
それでまあお釈迦様も随分可愛い
だから阿羅漢だからね
お釈迦様はもう何のことなく
阿羅漢になった人には私の息子やと呼んだりもするし
ですから もうお釈迦様も随分可愛がってあげたんですね
別にそれは希望してるわけじゃないし
もう阿羅漢ですからね
そこでクマーラカッサパというあだ名付けたんですね
それであだ名になってしまったんです
それでも一人で生活していたのは
後でどんどん大きくなってくると
一応まあその時でも若かって子供
ほぼ子供なんですけど
やっぱりこのアンダワナという大変生活きつい
もうかなりもう街から村からもうかなり離れている
もう誰も入らない 入りたがらない
森の中で一人で生活していたんです
でも立派な方だからね
たまたまこの偉い阿羅漢の方々いて
挨拶 挨拶ではなくて 会いに行ったりするし
時々お釈迦様もちょっと様子を見ようかなとかね
行ってみたりもしましたしね
また注釈書の物語はいろいろありますから
このアンダワナという森にもいろいろストーリーがあります
まあ一応あの まあそこら辺でまあまあストーリーをやめましょう
あまりにも長すぎることいっぱいあります
この このデーヴァタとパーリ語で女性名詞になってますけど
注釈書になってくるとやっぱり男性になるんですね
デーヴァプッタと書いているんです
それは私はわかりません
その神の性別は何なのかと
経典からもそれわからない
一応デーヴァタといえば女性名詞で使うしか方法ないし
このデーヴァプッタが
この神が この なんでわざとクマーラカッサパ尊者に噂とあって余計なことを言うんでしょうかと
やっぱりこの昔々からの友人でしたと
どんな昔からといえば
このカッサパ ブッダの時からの友人でしたと
そこでもまあ友人でしたと言ったっても
この場合でもあの人なんですね
あの5人が一緒に修行したんでしょうし
そこでこの2番目のお坊様が普賢果になって梵天に生まれ変わったんだから
その梵天の神がダールチーリヤというバーヒヤさんに回って
あんたはもううぬぼれるんじゃないよと脅したし
クマーラカッサパ尊者のところにも来て
もう訳の分からない質問するんですね
質問して これ質問なんです
質問してまだ訳してないんですけど
これはね あんたブッダに聞きなさいよと
やっぱり面倒見るんです
これの解釈はもう他の人にできませんと
質問してね これはブッダに聞きなさいよと
おそらくこの経典でクマーラカッサパ尊者阿羅漢になった経典かもしれません
それも書いてないね それも書いてない
とにかく自分の昔の友人にちょっと名前を記録させてあげるために
ちょっとした工夫した可能性もあります
そこでこのまた経典の方を見てください
クマーラカッサパン エータドボーチャと一番上の方にありましたね
クマーラカッサパ尊者にこのように言いましたと
それから言ったところはビクビク
アヤンマンミコラッティンドゥマーヤティティワパッチャラティ
呼ぶんだよ ビックービックーと
比丘よ ビックーと呼ぶのは年下なんです
年上の人が年下の人を比丘と呼ぶんです
お釈迦様の時代ではアヤスマンタという言葉を使います
それは最上の敬語ないというか
友達の間に交わす言葉なんですね
だからお釈迦様は比丘に比丘と言うんです
それ以外誰も比丘と呼ばないんですね
何でその神が失礼ではないかと
神々でもビックーとは呼ばないんです
お坊さんたちを バンテーカアヤスマンとか
あるいは徳のある人よとかいろいろ敬語を使うんですね
この場合は敬語を使ってない
だいたい梵天の神々だけ
そういう偉い梵天の神々だけ
出家の人々は仲間やと思ってるんだそうです
仲間と言ったっても こちら人間だから年下なんですね
向こうはものすごい昔からもう生きてる人々だからね
だから梵天の神様は自分たちの出家生活は随分長いと
まあそこら辺で生まれても出かけてるんだから
もし出家しているお坊さんに梵天の神が来て話を
だったら まあ随分一般的で
年下の人を呼ぶような言葉で呼んじゃうんです
大体経典でこういう言葉で判断するんで
神は誰ですかと 比丘と呼ばれてるんだから
当然その神が女性ではなくて
やっぱり梵天の神になっちゃうんですね
それではどの質問は これ質問というよりは
この神が言うのはあるなぞなぞというかね
あるたとえ話なんですね
たとえ話ではないんです
とにかくあるなぞなぞなんですね
あるなぞなぞを出しちゃうんですね
で パーリ語も少々難しいんですけど
日本訳に頼りながら 比丘よ比丘
このアリツカは 夜ですか？夜にですかね
夜に煙を出す  夜の煙を出し
昼に燃えていますと バラモンは次のように言いましたと
そこで比丘とバラモンは区別するんです
そこで比丘 このアリツカは夜ずっと煙を出していて
昼になったからもう燃えるんだと
そこでバラモンが来て
こういう風に言うんだよと
剣じゃよ これ刀ですかね
剣を持って掘りなさいと
とにかく剣でアリツカが掘れるかどうか分かりませんですけど
とにかくサッタンっていうのは何か剣という意味でもないんですよ
何か道具を持って 武器ですね
とにかく何か刃物でというかね
掘ってくださいと そこで掘るとしますね
アッデサ ランギン ランギー バンテー
門がありますということになりますね
門の方かんぬきを  そうですね
どこでしたっけ？うちに
これです  かんぬきですね
門じゃないね かんぬきを見ましたと
ロックですね 一応 それでかんぬきがありますと
バラモンは次のように言います
バラモンは次のように
かんぬきを取り除きなさい
そこでまた掘りなさいと
掘っていく途中で 次になんでしたっけ？カエル
カエルは ウッド マイカ
どうしてもわからなくなっちゃうんですね
なんでこのかんぬきの次は
小屋だったら分かりますけどね
すいません 神様とクマーラカッサと賢者とバラモンと
どういう関係？呼び方だけの関係
神様がこのストーリーをずっと言ってるんです
一方的に なぞなぞ出してるんですね
そこでこういうこと 神様が来てクマーラカッサ尊者に比丘よ
アリツカがありますと
そこでバラモンがこう言います
掘りなさいと そこでアリツカを掘る
掘ったところでかんぬきが見つかるという風に神がずっと言ってるんです
比丘がアリツカから剣を掘ったことによって剣を見つけた
見つけた  それは全く  掘るのは
誰も掘ってないんです
ただ この二人の会話だけなんです
これ会話もないんです
ここでクマーラカッサ尊者がいて
神が一方的に喋ってるんです
これ神が一方的に喋ってる言葉なんです
一言葉一言葉全部なぞなぞで意味がわからない
だからこれドラマ的に考えちゃうと
こちらでクマーラカッサ尊者がいて
こちら神がいて 神がガチャガチャガチャガチャ喋ってるんです
ただそれだけ クマーラカッサはなんだこれ？という風に聞いてるだけ
何やこれと 最初にくまれる
ビクショウと呼ばなくちゃね
比丘 アリスカがあります
それでバラモンが掘りなさいと言いますと
賢者よ 掘りなさいと言いますよ
賢者よ 掘りなさいとバラモンが言う
それで賢者が掘る 掘ったところでかんぬきが見つかる
それでかんぬきですよとバラモンに言う
それでバラモンが賢者よ
もっと掘りなさいと言う
という風にずっとストーリーを物語を言っているんです
一方的に うっと ウッドゥマーイカという言葉っていうのは随分珍しい言葉なんです
一般的なパーリ語でこのカエルに使う言葉っていうのはマンドゥカという言葉なんですけどね
ウッドゥマーイカおそらく上を見ているんだという意味かな
その意味にも取れるんだけど
やっぱりカエルの目がこちらにあるんだから
うーん わからないね そういう意味
ただウッドゥマーイカっていうのはカエルっていうことだからね
ウッドゥっていうのは上っていうことは
マーイカはね わからない
古い言葉なんです とにかく別か
謂いはちょっとわからないんですね
それでカエルが見つかると
それでウッキポウッドゥマーイカン
カエルも取り除けと さらに掘りなさいと
さらに掘りなさいと言ったらアッデサディダーパタン
次に出てくるのは カエルの次なんでしたっけ
分かれ道ですね 分かれ道
分かれ道がディダーパタンというのは二つに分かれるというね
二つに分かれる道が見つかるんだと
それももう取ってみなさいと
さらに掘りなさいと さらに掘るとチャンガーランというものに出会うんですね
容器ですね 器 入れ物を見せ
カーレパリッサーヴァ
あ 容器じゃない カーレパリッサーヴァ
まあなんか輿 という意味なんですけど
中で書いてないんですかね
まあいろいろ 容器は容器なんですけど
このいろいろ食器があるんですね
例えば昔臼で米なんか作るでしょ
そうすると大きい細かいものは粉とす使うし
それで漉しで漉して  ふるいと漉し
ふるいですね ふるいでしょうね
おそらく ふるいって意味なんですね
ですから 一つの食器と言えば容器と言えば容器で
それに入れて それから漉して必要なものは取るから
そこをなんとかするっていう
このふるいも取り除きなさいと
それからもう何か訳が分からないんですね
次に見つかるのは甕 なぞなぞ言ったって繋げないんですからね
ふるいですから 次にはもう台所ぐらいあればわかりますけど
台所どころいきなり甕が出て
それで甕も取っちゃうんですね
取りなさいと 次に出てくるのはもっとまだわからないこと
何でしたっけ  ここでは屠殺場と書いてありましていうと
お肉を切るナイフと包丁
アセソーナ  わかります？こちらの訳には屠殺場
ちょっと アセソーナ そちらは注釈書を見て訳してるんだが
アセソーナントィ マンスッチーダナアシンチェーヴァ・アビクッタなんじゃ
アセソーナっていうのはこの屠殺場で使う包丁のことなんですね
だからみんなすごい嫌がるものだと
台所で使う包丁とは違いますね
一応首を切って また肉を分けたりする場合は
日本でもやっぱり魚の売り場やらね
そういうところで使う刃物は違いますからね
だからこのちょっと気持ち悪いっていう意味で取りなさいということなんですね
いわゆる動物をね 首を切って肉を分ける専門家がね
その時使う刃物 アセソーナ
次に見つかるのは さらにそれも取り除いて
さらに掘る 掘るとマンスーペシンですね
肉の  肉片を その次が竜か
肉片が見つかるんですね
そこだけをつなげてるんですね
アセソーナ 刃物の次はもう切って捨ててる肉片があると
いわゆる使えない もう切って切って余分なものを捨てちゃいます
肉片が見つかるんだと
肉片も捨てて さらに掘るとナーガ
日本語は竜になってますね
どんな訳でいいでしょうかね
ナーガっていうのは蛇という意味なんですけど
蛇にもいろいろ言葉がありまして
例えば前の経典ではアラガッダ
で またね 違う言葉が出てきたし
で ナーガといえば大変尊敬されているんですね
ゾウにもナーガと言うんです
蛇にもナーガと言うんですね
やっぱりどちらでも使う場合は
すごく尊敬していて なんとなく人格
人格と言うんですか 人格化するんですね
人格化して喋っちゃうんです
それで竜にしているかもしれませんですけど
やっぱり竜の場合は違う言葉ありますけどね
ドラゴンとか  ドラゴンではないと思いますけど
ドラゴンにも使いますしね
ごちゃです とにかく インド文化でもドラゴンというのはやっぱり海の中に住んでるんですね
中国文化ではどこに住んでるんでしょうかね
ドラゴンの住所は 中国でも海の中じゃないの？ [笑い]インド仏典ではもうどうせ海の中
海の世界は龍の世界 で
でもインド的な仏典では龍っていうのは Dragon ではなくて
やっぱり蛇としては取っているんです
コブラとして コブラしか他の恐ろしい蛇のことを知りませんし
コブラはかなり尊敬されていましたからね
拝まれていましたしね
この場合はそこら辺にいる蛇コブラではなくて
あの 何と言いますか 神って言葉も入れなくちゃいけないんですね
イメージはコブラのイメージ
そうそう イメージはコブラのイメージ
中国とか日本の龍と違うんですね
違います 日本の中国の龍には足がついてますからね
いらんですけどね  龍神っていう言葉を使うっていうことでしょ
この場合 やっぱり龍神という訳でも悪くはないんですけどね
イメージは でもあの この足がついてる龍もこのお寺では描くんですけど
うーん まあ蛇というコブラというイメージなんですけど
いろいろストーリーだからこの変身できるんです
好きな形に時々 だからこのナーガが人間に変身して
人間の世界でウロウロしたりするんだそうと
その時は誤解したら困りますよと
なんかすごい格好いい人ではないかと言って
ちょっとちょっとちょっかい出しちゃうと
もともと龍ナーガだから
蛇だから ちょっとだけでも怒っちゃうと大変なことになるんだそうと
ですから それは気をつけろと
出家の場合でも この比丘戒を授ける場合は
あなたナーガですかと聞くんですね
その伝説的な謂れで 人間に化けて
蛇が人間に化けて出家しちゃうと
これで困りますと これあんたはナーガですか？と聞く
質問に答える それもこの伝説的な考え方から出ていることなんで
それでいえ 違いますよと返事させ出さなくちゃいけないんです
14 質問がありますからね
まあそういうことで とにかく最後にとにかくそうやってこの龍神というかね
まあえっと ナーガが見つかる
それでナーガがいますよと言ったら
そのままにしておくような
ティッテトナーガ ナーガを放っておき
放っておきなさいと そのまま
マーナーガンガッテーシ
ナーガには迷惑かけるなよと
ナモーカロヒナーガッサティ
ナーガには礼をしなさい
挨拶をしなさいと イメーコーター
これは質問だよと なぞなぞですよ
このなぞなぞを バガヴァンタン
ウプサンカミッタ プッチャイヤス
お釈迦様に会って聞きなさいよ
あんたにはわからないでしょうということ
あんたはこのなぞなぞ解けない
それはないんですけど
これはブッダに聞きなさいよと
これなぞなぞを解けるのはブッダかブッダの弟子たちか
どちらかでしょうと あるいはブッダの説法を聞いて
聞いて 人にもおそらく解くことはできるでしょうと
それ言ってその亀が消えちゃうんですね
クマーラカッサ尊者も困ったもんで
いきなりもう神が現れてきて
もうわけわからないなことを散々言われちゃって
全部シンボリックで また自分一人でこれつなげようと思ったって全くつなげないんですね
だから昼は煙が出て 夜が燃えている
ありすかでしょうし 掘るとまずかんぬきが出てきて
かんぬきが抜いてさらに掘っちゃうとカエルが出て
カエルは捨てちゃってさらに掘っちゃうと
次に出てくるのは何でしたっけ
あ 分かれ道 で それから篩が出てきて
それさらに言っちゃうと刃物が出てきて
次に肉片が出てきて それでヘビがいる
もう蛇と関係ない もう全然
もう カエルぐらいは関係あるんですけど
カエルとヘビは関係あって
肉片と刃物は何とか関係があって
他の篩と何でしたっけ
あれ かんぬきは家の中の道具だからね
関係あるし それで蜘蛛は何にも関係ないんですね
亀は 亀は一応どこか とにかく関係作るの大変なんです
次の説明に行きますかね
アタコーアヤスマークマーラカッサポー
タッサーラッティアッチャ
イエナイエナ バガワーテーヌ
プサンカミプサンカミッター
バガヴァンタン アビワーディット
アーエカマンタンニシーディー
その時クマーラカッサ尊者がその夜明けてからお釈迦様のところにいらっしゃる
いらっしゃって お釈迦様に礼をしてお座りになって
エーカマンタンニシンノーコー
教わってアヤスマークマーラカッサポー
バガヴァンタンエータドゥオ
お釈迦様にその話をするんですね
全部その話はまたもう一回行くんですね
で パッテーはアンタラだ
そんな話を私にして あの神が消えてしまったと
それでクマーラカッサ尊者が質問するんです
コーヌコーバンテーワンミコー
尊師 このありすかって何でしょうか
カーラッティンドゥーマーイェナ
夜煙出すということはどんな意味でしょうか
カーディワパッジャラナ
昼燃えるということはどんな意味でしょうか
コーブラームナ バラモンといって誰ですか
コースメード 賢者と言ったのは誰ですか
キンサッタン 掘る道具
掘る道具って何でしょうかね
キンアビッカナ 掘るということの意味は何ですか？だから全部言葉
言葉の意味を聞くんですね
カーランギ 次にこのかんぬきって何でしょうか
カーウドゥーマアイカ
カエルは何でしょうか
コーディダーパト 2つの分かれ道って何ですか
カーチャンガワーラン
ふるいは何でしょうか
コークンモ 亀は何でしょうか
カーアシスーナ 刃物 肉を切る刃物って何でしょうか
カーマンサピーシ 肉破片は何でしょうか
コーナーゴ ナーガって何でしょうかって聞くんですね
それでお釈迦様の定義が入ります
まあ全部終わるまではちょっと今日は時間ないですから
1つだけでも ワンミコティコビッコイマスセータンチャトゥマハブーティカッセカヤッサアビワチャナン
マータペッティカサンバワッサオーダナクンマーソウパチャヤッサ
アニッチャウッチャーダナパリマッダナベーダナヴィッダンサナダンマッサ
一番目の意味 ワンミカ
アリスカというのは ビッコイマスセータンチャトゥンマハブーティカッセカヤッサアビワチャナン
アリスカっていうのはこの体のことやと
体のことだと チャトゥンマハブーティカっていうのは地水火風でできている体ですよと
だから私はいろいろ説法でこの体は単なる機械物体だよと言ったら
かなりみんな違和感感じるんですけど
これはもう私は知ったことじゃないんです
これは違和感感じたって
ただの物体というふうに言ってますから
こちらでお釈迦様は体っていうのは地水火風でできているもので
その体 マータペッティカサンバワッサ
それから体がどのように現れるかというと
母と父から現れるんだと
いわゆる母がいて父がいると
そこで新しい体という物体が出てくるんですね
オーダナクンマーソウパチャヤッサ
それからオーダナっていうのはご飯
クンマーサっていうのは他のパンとかね
いろいろ食べ物ですね
そういうもので大きくする
だから全く仏教ではもう体はもうただの物体で扱ってます
ですから これはもうただの地水火風でできている体で
初めは両親から始めますけど
それからそれにご飯あげてパンあげて野菜あげて
いろんなことあげて大きく
どんどん大きくする 大きくする物体ということ
それからアニッチャウッチャーダナパリマッダナベーダナヴィッダンサナ
アニッチャウッチャーダナ
どんなことですか  無常の
アニッチャ 無常の その次の寂滅の
その次の摩滅 摩滅 その次の不浄
そこでこの 体のことをね
アニッチャ ちょっとしたことで変化する
だって小さな体にこのご飯やら小麦粉で作ったいろんな食べ物やらもうあげると大きくなるんだからね
それだけでも無常だからね
で それでウッチャーダナっていうのは
えっと 寂滅  この四つの下には悪臭を出す
悪い匂いを出す のどく
うっちゃん 決まってる定義があります
杜贯彻 以害他他害 他不礼等也
あ うっちゃーだな っていうのはこの体は一応この変化する
それで体いろいろ あの
何て言いますか いろんなものを塗ったり洗ったり
いろいろ手入れすることなんですね
うっちゃーだな っていうのはいろいろ手入れせないといけないんですね
そこでまあ なんで手入れするかというと
そうでなきゃものすごく臭くて
もう持てなくなっちゃうんですね
汚くて だからこの体にただ餌ご飯あげただけですくすくと大きくなるわけじゃないんです
いろいろご飯やらもう菜類をあげるんだけど
同時にもう洗ったり拭いたり
いろいろ塗ったり いろんな手入れしないといけないということで
うっちゃーだな パリマッドなということも
またいろいろ服を着せたり
守ってあげることですね
ベーゼナというのは壊れるということですね
ヴィッダンサナというのは消えてしまう
破壊と混乱  壊乱  あ 壊乱
壊れて乱れていく  壊乱の性質
とにかくどんどん大きくなるんだけど
もう途中で壊れるわ もう減っていくわ
最後に全部壊れてしまう
はじけてしまう その体にアリスカというんだよと
そこでなんでアリスカイコール体ですかっていうことはまた疑問なんですね
アリスカにはそうやって似てるところはありますかと
そこでブッダは似ているところは確かにありますよということ
アリスカっていうのは
あの 日本ではあまり見られません
いわゆる熱帯の国々ではよく見られるんですね
これをアリスカと言っても
本当はシロアリなんです
シロアリは随分立派なアリスカを作るんです
もうかなりのものは作るんです
アフリカ見ただったらもうものすごいデッカいものも作るんですね
だいたいアリスカっていうのは結構まあ
例えばこの土地の面積から見ても
我々はここら辺にちょっとシロアリが出ているんだったら
もう気をつけろと 家を作る場合はと
なぜかというと そこら辺ちょっとだけなんで
掘ってみると全部もう中アリスカなんです
どこまで掘って掘って作っていくかとかわからないんです
そこであっちこっちから上に上がってきて
上にも作っていくんですね
時々何かブス像みたいに
かなりそんな大きくはないんだけど
結構大きく作ったりします
で そこで下を掘ってみると
全部そこら辺の土地をね
もう掘ってるんですね
でまあ シロアリに作られる土っていうのは
もう粘土としては随分いいものなんです
質はいいんです 普通の土を口で食べて
唾液で練ってあれ作るんです
ですから かなりの仕事なんです
どのくらいの高さに  高さはそんなにね
1メートル  2メートルぐらいかもしれませんだけど
この下の世界はね かなりなんです
だからその土で 粘土で人間には
まあ家は 2 3軒は軽々と作れます
だから我々スリランカの場合も
壁とか土で作りますから
土はどんな土でも練っても役に立ちません
粘着力はないんです それでアリスカを掘るんです
アリスカもアリはいつでもアリではなく
シロアリスカですけど
シロアリいつでもいるわけじゃないんです
大体作って古くなっちゃうと
まあそこは捨てて他のところに行くんです
あるいはこの女王アリ
死んじゃうと もうそれで全部終わりでしょうしね
ですから あっちこっち作る
まあ野生の場合はもう別に何の迷惑もないんですけどね
まあ家の中に入り込んじゃうと
もう家は全部潰しちゃいますからね
まあスリランカは家はあまり気は使いませんからね
やっぱり壁は土でしょうし
ですから そんなに派手な迷惑見えませんだけど
土の中でまた また再びそれを噛んで
また作って作って屋根に行くんです
だから土で壁作っている建物っていうのは
大体屋根は葉っぱなんですね
これは 1 日 2 日で食べちゃいます
だから一旦出たらもうどうにもならないんですね
材木  材木食べますから
材木は当然食べますね
日本の場合は建物丸ごとにかじーんと
土台の 倒れちゃいますからね
よく食べます でもシロアリはどこに行ってもちゃんと道を作っていくんですね
だって 材木の上に行ったっても歩かない
見えるように 太陽体に触れちゃう
死んじゃうんですね ですから
先に進むために土を持ってきて
またトンネルを作って先に進む
また土を持ってきて トンネルを作って先に進む
だからアリはシロアリ見えませんだけど
シロアリの道はど派手に見えるんです
だから餌探しに行くと
ちゃんとトンネルを作りながら行くんですね
それはリスとかね 動物食べちゃいますからね
シロアリを リスなんかは見たらもう全部もうこうしてこうしてこうして食わしても簡単に壊せます
トンネルだけだったらね
シロアリを見つけては食べる
見つけては食べる シロアリも大変ですね
ここら辺に餌が木材があります
これ食べましょうと思ったら
まずトンネルを作って
まあ日本でこの同じことでしょうね
このトンネルもまず上から全部囲って中掘ってるでしょうにね
あれとね 似てる仕事ですけど
それでアリ塚っていうのはかなりそうやって土でできているものっていうことで
それで地水火風で体ができて
だから材料は単純 アリ塚には
この自分たちが細いトンネルを作るんだけど
自動的に大きな穴ができちゃうんです
だから壁の中に生活しているんですね
こちら壁を作ってて こちらから壁を作ってっちゃうと
真ん中きちんと穴があるんです
そこで土は掘っては持っていくでしょうね
どんどん穴だらけなんで
中は で これかなり空気が通る
空洞できちゃうんですね
そこでこの大きな空洞の中にまた穴を掘って
そちらにこのなんかミツバチのあれみたいにものを作って
そこで卵を産むんですね
アリはほんの小さいんですけど
女王アリ アリじゃないよ
これシロアリです 女王シロアリはかなりに大きいんです
これぐらいかな  8 センチ
10 センチぐらい大きいんです
想像できないんで シロアリとこれぐらい差がありますから
動きません お腹の方すごい長くて
口体の方が普通です 普通
普通のシロアリの 1倍
2倍ぐらい 体の方が 顔と体
3つに分けますね 虫の場合
虫 昆虫の場合はね で だから頭の方と胸の方と胴体の方
胴体の方がものすごい大きい
全部卵ですからね とにかくもう
だからもう何万単位で産まないとね
で それでみんな一生懸命
とにかくそちらは卵を産むだけの仕事で
で 餌はどういう運ぶでしょうね
他のアリたちが そこまではわかりませんね
だから女王のシロアリを取らない限りは
アリ塚とは攻撃したっても何の意味もないんです
いくら切っても いくら掘って捨てたっても何の意味もないんです
だからとにかく掘って掘って掘って
女王アリを見つけた 女王のシロアリを見つけ-そっちを捕まっちゃえばね
いいことなんですけど
難しいんですね それでそうやっていっぱい行動ができるんだから
いろんな動物がその中に生活する
ヘビとかトカゲとか それからネズミとか
だからアリ塚っていうのは一寸でも危険なものなんです
シロアリ塚だから もうシロアリは別にそんなに木材食べるだけでね
もう別に毒持ってるわけでもないし
もう何の問題もないんです
野生の中だったらシロアリがいた方が一番役に立つしね
全部食べる 我々の場合
人間も役に立ってますから
家を作れますから 普通の土で家作れませんよ
とにかくアリ塚を掘らないと
アリ塚を掘ったらきちんとした粘土
よく頑張って作ってくれるんだから
そこにちょっと水を入れて
また何か粘着のあるものなんか入れて
よーく練って練って壁を作ればすごい綺麗な色
日本の土の壁の色 全くその色なんです
何も色を染める必要ないんです
すごい綺麗です だからその点では役に立ちますけどね
その土そのまま持ってきて塗っちゃえば
でももうちょっと何か粘着ある何かあった方がいいとは思いますけどね
なくても結構色が水分も落ち着く気持ちのいい色なんですね
それで土の壁作ったらもう家の中は涼しいというと素晴らしく涼しいんです
外はもう三十度であろうとも
中は冷房付きという感じで
だからその点ではものすごい
それから体にも決して悪くはないし
役に立ちますけどね だからといってアリ塚っていうのはやっぱり安全な場所じゃない
ヘビが住んでいる いろんなトカゲが住んでいる
だから我々のことわざでも
アリ塚に手を出したんだよという場合のことわざまでもあるんですね
とんでもない余計なことに引っかかったと
命もなくなるほどの 全財産がなくなるほどのとんでもないことに
バカみたく手を出すことに
我々はアリ塚に手を出すというんです
アリ塚 これいい立派な穴ではないかと手を出すところで
ここでヘビがいて噛んじゃう
それで終わりですからね
そういうふうなことでこの穴がある
このアリ塚にもあっちこっち個々の穴があるんだ
そこでいろいろ住んでいるんだと
この中にも生き物もいるし
また仏教の場合 ありとあらゆる病の住処ですよと
体には簡単につくのはね
住んでくれるのは病だからね
ですから体っていうのは病
様々な病の住処である
穴がいっぱいあるということでアリ塚に例えるんだよと
えーと ミッドタウンの旦那さんそれでアリ塚だけで終了します
先生 アリ塚のところで夜に大体がなさそうだけど
時間にします 一言一句は定義ありますからね
五分で全部終わってほしいのであれば五分でできますけど
夜は煙出すということは
夜くだらないことを考えているということで
昼は燃えているということは昼は行動しているんだということで
そうやっても言えますけど
全部 賢者っていうのは修行者のことで
掘る刃物っていうのはサティのことで
そう言っちゃうと意味がなんか死んでしまいますからね
ブラフマのはお釈迦様のことです
うん